- Hey everybody, Dr. Sammy here,
your friendly neighborhood entomologist.
And today, we're gonna
talk about photosynthesis.
There's very little life on this planet
that could exist without photosynthesis.
It is the prerequisite for pretty much
everything you see around you.
It's how you get from the
intangible light of the sun
to physical bodies like
those of humans are
hungry, hungry caterpillars.
But what does photosynthesis
actually mean?
I hear people say all the
time, that photosynthesis
is the process by which
plants make sugar from light.
And it almost seems like magic.
Light is not a substance.
It is not made up of the
molecular building blocks
that compose all matter.
And thus, it doesn't have mass.
You can fill a room with light
and never run out of space.
So how could you possibly make
something physical out of it?
Well, you can't.
So, instead light is a form of energy,
energy being the capacity to do work.
So, this is where it's
helpful to know word origin.
The word photosynthesis is
made up of two Greek words.
It literally means light and
to put together, that's right.
In addition to being an entomologist,
a double a little bit in
etymology, just to make sure
I'm maximally confusing to people.
Anyway, you're literally
using light to drive reactions
that combine ingredients into
new products, a form of work.
So you're not turning light
itself into material sugar.
You're taking matter that
already exists in the form of
six molecules of carbon dioxide,
six molecules of liquid water,
and using the energy of
the sun to power a reaction
that combines them into a new substance
with molecular oxygen as a byproduct.
Think of it this way.
When you bake a cake, you
don't say that you made cake
from heat.
It would be more accurate to say
that you took flour,
eggs, sugar, and butter
and used heat to combine
them into something new.
So sticking with our analogy,
the ingredients for photosynthesis
are just carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and
water from the ground,
with light to do the heavy lifting.
Carbon dioxide and water are put together
to produce a carbohydrate
which literally means
water and carbon.
As you can see with this
typical carbohydrate molecule,
glucose, your carbon is
attached to the same atoms
that compose water, two
hydrogens and oxygen.
This carbohydrate has more chemical energy
or bond energy than the molecules
of water or carbon dioxide
that served as ingredients.
Thus, the energy at the end
of the process is much greater
than the energy that the
ingredients had at the outset.
This means that photosynthesis
is a sort of useful reaction
that stores energy like a
big biochemical solar cell.
We call these endergonic reactions.
And you might be able to see already
why they will be so valuable
in biological systems.
You take molecules that
don't have much energy
and use them to produce
something that can do work.
And the kitchen where
all this work happens
is the chloroplast.
Literally, the green maker.
The chloroplast is a
little organ or organelle
present in some plant cells.
And it's what makes plant cells
and ultimately plants green.
And this is because the
chloroplasts bear the green pigment
chlorophyll.
Now the same way that
the word photosynthesis
can be broken down neatly
into its two base words.
The process itself can
be separated into two
neat little segments.
I like to think of them
as a charging step,
where energy from light is
converted into chemical energy
and synthesis step where the
energy is used to do the work
of actually synthesizing the end product,
typically a carbohydrate.
So the first segment requires
the direct input of light
and as such is referred to as
the light dependent reactions.
These happened in a
section of the chloroplast
called the thylakoids.
They form these neat little pouches.
The inside of which is called
the lumen and the outside
called the stroma.
When a photon of light ends
it's eight minute journey
from the surface of the sun
to the surface of a leaf
its energy is absorbed by the chlorophyll
embedded in the thylakoid membrane.
This energy powers a pump which
literally charges the inside
of the thylakoids like a battery
by moving the ions inside.
As the charge builds up, the
energy can be used to do work.
But the next segment of
this process happens outside
of the thylakoids in the stroma.
So they get that energy where it's needed.
The thylakoids transfers the energy
to a molecule called ADP,
adenosine diphosphate.
By adding another phosphate bond
and making it ATP, adenosine triphosphate.
Now you might've heard of this one.
It's often called the
energy currency of the cell.
Pretty much wherever energy
is needed for cell to do work
ATP is involved.
You might have also heard that
the energy is stored inside
of the phosphate bonds,
and that breaking them
releases the energy.
But try to remember that these
bonds depicted by the lines
in these diagrams are just a convention.
It represents an adherence
of these atoms together
via attraction, and it
shows you where they adhere.
But the energy isn't actually in the bond,
the attraction between the
atoms builds up potential energy
like a rubber band that's
being pulled really tightly.
When you let it go, it
could hit a paper cup
and do the work of displacing that cup.
The rubber band then falls to the ground
in a low energy state because
it's energy has been released.
So when you put the energy into a system
great enough to overcome the
attraction between the atoms
and force them apart,
thereby breaking the bonds,
atoms or in this case
a whole phosphate group
can go spiraling off taking what was
potential energy with it.
If it hits something that it can bond with
that energy is released
as the bond is formed
and can be used to do work
such as the magic of ATP
is described as energetic
because it's easy
to break the bond between it
and the last phosphate group.
Meaning you don't have
to put much energy in
but you get a ton of energy out.
So back to the thylakoids.
Those photons of light were able to net us
a highly energetic ATP molecule.
But the next segment of photosynthesis
is gonna need some electrons too.
That light energy is used to do the work
of loading up a mobile
electron carrier with electrons
and a proton.
This carrier is called NADP plus.
And when it's got a full
load to take to the next
set of reactions, it's called NADPH,
and that's pretty much the
light dependent reactions
in a nutshell.
The only other thing you should
probably remember is that,
well, this is where all the
oxygen in your lungs comes from.
So, you know, no big deal.
When chlorophyll gets excited
by that photon of light
it turns into a real bully.
The work it's doing
creates such a powerful
electro-chemical imbalance
and the chlorophyll
balances the equation by
just stealing an electron
from water.
This causes water to fall
apart releasing its oxygen
which the plant just lets go of.
So now that we've taken
care of the section
that's dependent on light,
let's discuss the section
that isn't.
The light independent
reactions or the Calvin cycle
occur in the stroma of the chloroplast.
And this is where the earth shattering
chemical reaction occurs
that allows for all life
on this planet.
The fixation of gaseous
carbon or inorganic carbon
into carbon chains, organic carbon.
And this is so important because fixation
doesn't just happen on its own.
CO2 in the atmosphere doesn't
form organic chains or sugars.
When it bumps into more
CO2 in the atmosphere
it requires the help of
enzymes and energetic molecules
made by living organisms.
It's why when we first
landed a rover on Mars
we immediately started
looking for the evidence
of organic molecules.
It will be evidence that
something is or was living there.
In the light independent
reactions a plant enzyme
fixes carbon dioxide from the
air into a chain of carbon.
So ATP and NADPH which were produced
in the light dependent
reactions, provide the energy
and the electrons to create two
energetic reactive molecules
that can be combined to make glucose
or other useful molecules.
And the beauty of it
is that the byproducts
of the light independent
reactions, ADP and NADP plus
are shuttled off from the
stroma back to the thylakoids
for more light dependent reactions
where they can be recharged and recycled
for use again later.
And, wow, photosynthesis.
The takeaway here is that photosynthesis
allows you to go from the
intangible energy of the sun
to the stored chemical energy
that life on this planet is based on.
The sun's energy is converted
to the chemical energy
of a carbohydrate molecule
in the chloroplast.
That molecule can later be broken down
in most of that energy
reclaimed either by the plant
or by creatures that eat that plant.
All life on earth is carbon-based.
And every single molecule of that carbon
once existed in the
atmosphere in gaseous form
as carbon dioxide until
some enterprising plant
or microorganism synthesized
it into something you can use.
And while they were added many
of them filled the atmosphere
with the oxygen that
we all need to breathe.
So the next time you see a plant,
shake its leaf and say thank you.